états unis on n'en finit plus de parler
du sida ce mal mystérieux qui s'est
propagée surtout dans la communauté
homosexuelle et qui s'est révélé mortel
pour près de 500 personnes
le fait qu'on ne sache toujours pas
guérir ce mal commence à provoquer un
véritable vent de panique dans tout le
pays
il faut rappeler qu'une cinquantaine de
cas ont été décelés en france aux états
unis le sida le syndrome
d'immunodéficience acquise frappe
surtout trois catégories de personnes
les homosexuels les drogués et les
haïtiens tout cela est bien étrange
l'enquète de notre correspondant à
washington edwards
texas les premiers signes d'un vent de
panique qui balaye l'amérique chez ceux
qui sont supposés entre et les premiers
en contact avec les malades secouristes
ambulanciers
on prend un minimum de précautions sens
très bien savoir si ça servira à quelque
chose
4 si j'attrape cette maladie au contact
de quelqu'un je ne sais pas si je n'ai
pas la transmettre à ma famille ça
m'inquiète beaucoup
j'ai vu des articles sur la
contamination par les banques du sang
c'est très grave
ça pourrait être un fléau
un truc comme ça pourrait tuer des tas
de gens et contaminer toute la
population la panique à cleveland dans
l'un des plus grands centres de
transfusion sanguine en californie où
l'on a interdit dans les écoles les
cours de respiration artificielle et à
new york où les employés des maisons
funéraires refuse de toucher au corps
des morts de la maladie des homosexuels
aient enfin ici même à washington où les
autorités municipales ont donné l'ordre
à tous les médecins de communiquer à
l'institut
de la santé les noms de leurs patients
atteints de cette maladie sous peine de
se voir infliger une amende de 300
dollars et 90 jours de prison
6 144 morts en deux ans sur les 1600 41
cas officiellement enregistrés mais le
problème est que chaque mois je dis bien
chaque mois on en compte 165 de plus
dont 70% chez les homosexuels et que les
médias ne font rien pour calmer la
panique
par exemple cette émission de télévision
à dallas au texas où un prêtre dans sa
chronique journalière a publiquement mis
en garde
toute la population est de cette façon
c'est un fléau une maladie qui affecte
la communauté homosexuelle et elle
contamine maintenant la communauté
hétérosexuels
les enfants et les bébés baisse autre
exemple ce commentaire d'un autre
pasteur au cours d'une émission de radio
très populaire est toujours sur le même
sujet beaucoup d'homosexuels sont dans
la restauration
qu'est ce qui nous prouve qu'en touchant
la nourriture il ne transmettent pas la
maladie à leurs clients ou encore ce
commentaire d'un médecin si on est
contre les porteurs d'une maladie il
faut les isolés que ce soit des vaches
des sages ou des homosexuels en moins 15
ans mo5 ue
de vouloir proscrire l'homosexualité si
ridicule cette maladie est un prétexte
dont ils se servent et les malheureux
qui en sont atteints sont des boucs
émissaires
c'est une véritable contre on n'arrive
pas à maîtriser cette panique la peur
est beaucoup plus répandu que la maladie
et les gens en fait pandore des groupes
précis n'ont rien à craindre de cette
maladie est désarmé devant ce qui les
touche essentiellement les milieux
homosexuels s'organise aujourd'hui de
san francisco à new york pour réclamer
ouvertement dans les rues une aide du
ministère de la santé
voilà donc